a year ago America's technology
billionaires were soaring with markets
near all-time highs and VCS pumping
money into startups today stock prices
have dropped and inflation surged making
the members of the Forbes 400 list of
the richest people in the U.S a
collective 500 billion dollars poorer
than last year the wealthiest Tech
tycoons have taken the brunt of the
beating they've lost a combined 315
billion dollars in net worth since the
fall of 2021 accounting for nearly
two-thirds of the total drop in the
Forbes 400's wealth the biggest losses
have come from the biggest fortunes
Amazon's Shares are down 27 percent
taking 50 billion dollars off Jeff
bezos's net worth and dropping him from
the top spot on the list for the first
time since 2018. Microsoft stock down by
15 helped knock 13.5 billion dollars off
the fortune of former CEO Steve Ballmer
it also hurt Microsoft co-founder Bill
Gates but not as much Gates's Fortune
was down 20 8 billion dollars with most
of that due to a 20 billion dollar
donation to his Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation in July in an effort to ramp
up the mega foundation's giving and no
company illustrates the end of the
pandemic boom more than video
conferencing company Zoom which is down
73 in the last year as workers returned
to the office bad news for a Founder
Eric Wan Who's down 10.6 billion dollars
others in Tech adjacent Fields were hit
too the 315 billion dollar decline in
wealth does not include for example the
76.8 billion dollar drop in Mark
Zuckerberg's Fortune due to a plummet in
shares of Facebook parent company meta
Forbes categorizes social media
billionaires like Zuckerberg as part of
the media and entertainment sector
Twitter founder Jack dorsey's net worth
was also down this year by 10.4 billion
dollars thanks to the falling share
price of Twitter and block the parent
company of payment processor Square
those stocks were down 40 and 76 percent
respectively
[Music]